junto a los restos del avión más grande
del mundo el ministro de defensa de
ucrania premia a las tropas
con el límite y rubén con el aeródromo
de host o mail uno de los primeros
lugares ocupados por rusia a finales de
febrero vuelve a estar bajo control
ucraniano el pueblo de quien reza por
usted y por que echemos a esos infames
de todo nuestro país desde el fondo de
mi corazón gracias sin embargo la
celebración es silenciosa la batalla se
ganó a un costo enorme
no no puedo decirte cómo fue
esto no es la victoria todavía es sólo
el comienzo
la victoria será cuando todo se hayan
ido cuánta pena las ciudades de este
distrito quedaron devastadas hasta el
domingo por la tarde se habían
encontrado más de 400 cadáveres de
civiles en la región de kiev el recuento
final será mayor pero este barrio parece
haberse salvado de lo peor de la
violencia no arde también
los rusos estuvieron aquí fueron de casa
en casa buscando algo no sé qué buscaban
su puerto poco de reseña
desde el 4 de marzo no tenemos
electricidad ni agua ni gas así que
cocinamos nuestra comida aquí fuera
la falta de electricidad también
significa que no hay noticias así que
parte de la tarea de los soldados aquí
ahora es informar
los rusos dicen que quieren establecer
su control sobre toda la región de
doñetsk lugansk
así que habrá una escalada y si
inevitablemente pero les hemos
bombardeado tanto que sus unidades ya no
están preparadas para el combate esta
columna de avance fue destruida hace
tres semanas los cuerpos de los soldados
rusos aún yacen esparcidos en los
alrededores propios ocupantes rusos
intentaban utilizar esta carretera para
llegar a kiev desde justo mail a través
de espn hicimos explotar el puente y las
unidades del ejército ruso en la guardia
nacional así como sus vehículos por lo
que este es el lugar donde se tuvo
definitivamente su avance sobre kiev
aunque están orgullosos de esta victoria
y se sienten aliviados de que la región
de kiev esté ahora libre de las tropas
rusas los ucranianos también se
preguntan cuál podría ser la venganza de
los rusos